- Hey everybody.
I'm really excited about this interview.
So for everybody's who's
watching on LinkedIn,
let's put in your phone numbers.
We're gonna call somebody.
In LinkedIn Live,
put in your phone number
and your question,
and then the team's gonna pick which ones.
But I have the super
handsome, wildly accomplished
Daymond John in the building.
- You can't say that when I'm right next
to Milli Vanilli's album.
- Oh, you like that, right.
I'm excited about that.
Blame it on the rain.
- "Powershift," when's this out?
- March 10th.
- [Gary] It's February 24th.
The recording's probably
out in a couple days,
so do you want us to launch
or do you have any
preference on launching?
We'll figure that out after we talk.
- Yeah, we'll figure it out whenever.
- We'll figure it out.
Daymond's got a new book.
It's called "Powershift."
I'm excited to be with him.
We've jammed a bunch.
At one point, we're gonna be very old men
and look back to our films together.
- Yup.
- And that's gonna be fun.
Obviously, wildly accomplished
entrepreneur, star,
one of the stars of "Shark Tank,"
but more importantly for me,
I'm starting to get really, like,
weird as I get older.
Meaning I've gotten very focused,
even recent times even
more around kindness,
and like, who do I wanna be around?
Who do I just genuinely,
I saw you very recently,
maybe four to seven, eight, 10 weeks ago
at a keynote that we were
both speaking at an event.
And I saw you for a brief second
'cause you spoke and I
was in the green room,
I was running up, and like,
it was really interesting.
I was on stage, they're
just kind of announcing me,
we saw each other, we dapped it up,
and as I was walking onstage,
I literally was speaking to myself
before I said hello to the crowd of like,
it's really funny when you like somebody,
what happens with your
chemicals in your body.
It happened when I just
saw you in the lobby,
and it's happening right now.
I like nice.
And so, for all your accomplishments,
obviously I don't know
you all the way through,
and haven't been in enough situations,
but for me, personally, from what I know,
I really appreciate your niceness,
and I think you're a nice human.
That's the nicest thing I can say.
And so, I'm glad you're on the show.
- I think the same, yeah.
- I appreciate it.
- I think when we see each other,
we've talked about getting
the families together,
but you and I probably realize
that shit ain't gonna happen.
- Or it will.
It's like you get streaky, yeah.
- It will, but it's no pressure, right?
No pressure.
- It's all gonna happen.
- Yeah, and that's the type of stuff
I talk about, you know, in the book.
- Tell me about the book.
- Well, we'll get into it.
- [Gary] What's going on with you?
You look good.
The show's going--
- I'm feeling good.
Everything's going well
it seems like, from afar.
- You know, I just turned 51 yesterday.
- Happy birthday.
- I thought I was gonna,
thank you, I thought I was
gonna wake up a little smarter,
and I thought the world was gonna change,
and I'm a little disappointed, man.
And I was calling today Moron Monday.
- [Gary] Because?
- I got a question for you, man.
- [Gary] Please.
- Why people so fuckin' stupid?
There's a lot of fuckin'
stupid people out there.
- Well, how do you mean it?
- Well, here's what happened.
- How do you define stupid?
- Here's why I'm stressed today.
The first day of 51,
'cause people still morons.
I put up something I saw on Media Black
something something something,
and it broke down and said,
"You know what?
"Do you realize that
"the inspiration for X-Men for Stan Lee
"was Malcolm X and Martin Luther King?"
I didn't know that.
- I didn't know that either.
- Magneto is Malcolm X.
Destroy the world, fuck
'em, they don't like us.
And Xavier is, "Chill out."
The inspiration for it.
- Interesting.
Is that true?
That's fuckin' cool.
- So, I'm not gonna jump
around and just assume, right?
I go and do my research.
I find various articles.
History Channel with people.
I put in a link in my bio,
and I represented Stan Lee
for the last five years
before he passed, as licensing his name.
I called his family and said,
"Is this true?"
Everybody confirmed.
- That's neat.
- Most of the people on there said,
"I didn't know it's true,
I did know it's true."
But there was about 5%--
- I see, I'm sorry, I'm now following.
I think I'm following you.
You posted this.
- Posted this.
- And when you're saying
most of the people,
you're talking about--
- And I showed the data
and I said if you want to,
go to my link to check this out.
- You mean comments in your post.
- Comments, comments.
- Go ahead.
- Show pictures of him and I.
Obviously, I'm pretty accomplished.
I've been around some really great people.
- [Gary] Yup.
- Half of the morons out of the 5% were,
"It's not true."
- The 2.5, 2.5%.
- Right, so 2.5, "It's not true."
These are the people
that only get one source
of information from any
place and every place,
and they don't--
- Do you think it was a racist statement?
Like, just straight up,
I'm just curious.
- Well, I'll be very honest.
- [Gary] Probably, right?
Maybe, I don't know.
- Yeah, there was racism on both sides.
I'll tell you why.
Because the ones who said it wasn't true,
happen not to be of
African-American descent.
- Okay.
- The other half happened to be
of African-American descent and said,
"Well, then, why didn't
he just make them Black?"
- [Gary] Get lost, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- All right.
Number one, if he woulda made them Black,
this would've been called
the Martin Luther King
and Malcolm X Chronicles,
and we've already seen that
in how it was going down.
He got inspired.
- Right.
- Doesn't mean the entire
context of the entire
body of X-Men is Malcolm
X and Martin Luther King.
And the other half of the ignorant ones,
just didn't do their homework.
It's right there in front of you.
All you had to do was read the link,
and then go and do your research.
- I think--
- Why, why, what, what?
But here's the good news.
If there's more morons like that,
then you and I, and
the hard-working people
watching this, with common
sense, and homework,
and busting their ass can survive.
Can thurish.
- You know what's interesting?
You know, it's really interesting
where my brain goes on this.
I'm deeply,
you know what's funny?
Like, I don't know, like I understand
what you're saying, period.
Next sentence.
It's wild to me how much
that doesn't upset me.
It actually, like, it doesn't upset me.
Humans are humans.
When I see stuff like
that, I'm more grateful
because I've been
thinking a lot about like,
what makes somebody not like something.
- [Daymond] Yeah.
- And when I see anybody not liking,
look, I think the big, you know,
it makes me grateful that I do.
I'll give you a good example.
I was just thinking about this,
and it's perfect with you.
Like, every time you're winning,
as an entrepreneur, right?
And there's a world right
now where entrepreneurs
are superheroes.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- And let's call it,
there's 500 entrepreneurs
that probably have attention
at a superhero level.
Some people are Superman and Spiderman.
Ya, know Jeff Bezos, Elon Musk.
Other people are, you
know, Rogue from X-Men.
Everyone sits in a spot.
It's been really interesting.
I'm uncomfortably competitive.
Like, I wildly wanna win at all times.
However, in parallel, as a contradiction,
I think the world is so abundant,
that I really cheer for
people when they get wins.
- [Daymond] I love it.
- Yeah, like, I wanna win.
And do I think I'm competing
with every other entrepreneur?
I do.
At the same token,
I know I'm not competing
with any other entrepreneur,
and the world is abundant.
Anyway, this is one
long-winded thing to say
of if you have the energy
to dislike or hate,
or drag down or tear down buildings,
shit's not good in your soul.
- True, but if you are just not even
going to the point of hating,
I don't think they hated.
They just made comments
without doing their research.
Now, what's going on in their life,
because what they sit around?
And listen, maybe some of those
people are super successful.
I don't know.
- [Gary] Yeah, I don't think it's success.
- But there's something not going on
and they're like why don't
you look and say, "Why?"
- So, to me it's not whether it's hate.
It's like the energy to try
to tear something else down.
- Yeah.
- Whatever you wanna call it.
Look, I think the greatest
thing is happening right now.
The internet, in its current state,
people call it social media,
call it whatever you want.
The internet in its current
state is exposing human beings
at a level we've never seen before.
And everyone thinks
everything is super bad,
and I think this is the
beginning of the greatest era
of the human race.
I genuinely believe that.
I genuinely believe that the fact
that we're now getting a
better view of ourselves,
is gonna lead to very
interesting good behavior
hundreds of years from now.
I really believe that.
- The more the data,
the more the information is out there,
the more you can scrape in.
- Everyone's like, "Oh, now it sucks.
"'cause social media FOMO, all this."
I'm like, we've always been insecure.
- We've always been.
- 99% of people are insecure.
- Yeah.
- Or whatever, it's 92 or 79,
a stunning amount of people are insecure,
and when you're insecure,
the way to mask that
is to buying things to disguise it,
and tearing down others.
Judgment.
- Yeah.
Well there it is.
- So there it is.
- Anyway, so that was eating me all day.
- That was how your 51st birthday started.
I'm pumped.
I'll be honest with you,
I'm more pumped because that makes,
I'm like thrilled that now I know
how the X-Men was inspired.
Which is fuckin' epic.
- And so then he would go on and obviously
do all the ones, one other one.
Now, this is where I need to fact check
'cause I haven't had time.
I had heard it right after I posted it.
That when he did "Black
Panther," I believe,
they said something in the nature of,
like in three series in or five,
and maybe we can check
it while we're here.
"Hey, you need to have some
people of other colors,
"some white people in, you know,
"with the "Black Panther" thing."
So, I believe, the next one he put in
was the Black Panther beating up the KKK.
So, that's what he did.
But we have to fact check that one.
We have to fact check that.
- Black Panther's first
appearance was what?
In "Fantastic Four?"
Did I nail that?
Let's go.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Anyway, it's something.
- Why'd you write this book?
- Why'd I write this book?
- You were under contract
and you need to bang 'em out?
- No.
- No, that's good.
- No, no, no, no, no.
It's extremely hard.
I'm dyslexic.
And, you know, so I wrote
this book because it was about
one week that I got, as we
all get our things from people
all the time, and they
were asking me how to
create change in their lives.
And I've seen you say it often.
"You're not gonna do anything right
"after I tell you this."
Right?
- Yeah.
- Most of them, right?
And they were all using
and masking it with,
"Well, here's my job.
"Here's this and that."
you know, Warren Buffet said
something really amazing.
You may go throughout
various aspects of your life,
but the only thing that you are
fully in control of is yourself.
And I realized that people
just didn't understand
what they can do today to make them better
for tomorrow and the next
day and the next day.
And it was all about negotiation.
I think the thing that
makes me or somebody else
more successful, let's
just say, it's all of
the aspects of what we negotiated in life.
First of all, with ourselves.
Second of all, with the
surrounding and the families
or whatever the case is.
Third of all, with our position.
Listen, I was born Black.
That's not gonna change.
I'm not gonna be Chinese,
white, or yellow tomorrow.
That is what it is, and that's what it is.
Get over it, move forward,
use it as an asset
in any place that I can,
whatever the case is.
So, people always thought that negotiation
and those things of that
nature to create change
is either you having all
the power or somebody else
taking the power from you or
they gotta give it to you.
And it's not that way.
- Which leads to deep unhappiness.
- [Daymond] Exactly.
- The second you think
somebody else is in control,
you're in big trouble.
- When somebody else is in
control of your destiny,
you're in big trouble.
But--
- I think about this a lot,
and obviously it falls into
race and gender issues,
but I actually think about
it in parenting dynamics.
So much.
- And it happens when,
and this is a three part.
You have to build influence,
you have to then negotiate,
and you have to nurture
a long relationship
because this part of the relationship
where you just had created
some kind of value,
is nothing in comparison to here.
And it has to all be concise,
and I don't think people understand that.
So, if somebody said,
if I'm in an elevator with Gary Vee
I never thought I would see Gary.
He was in Oklahoma.
I never thought I would
see Gary Vee in my life.
How'm I gonna build influence with him
when I got 90 seconds?
Listen, first of all, make sure the pitch
you say really quick is, you know,
what's in it for Gary.
How you've been doing really well with it.
And the fact that you're
gonna be successful
with or without him or
not, but if you have,
if you can offer some
opportunity to him, let him know.
Your influence is when Gary and his team
is gonna go back and look at
the shit you've been saying
for the last 10 years on social media.
Good, bad, or indifferent.
They're either gonna say, I
want this person around me.
or I don't want this person around me.
And it's not just you.
You're hanging out with
this person right here,
who you would never bring to Gary's office
because he's a alcoholic or
a misogynist or racist pig.
Stop taking pictures with him,
posting them all over your site,
'cause Gary's not just looking there.
Gary's looking everywhere around you,
and people don't understand how important
the influence was that
they had to build prior
to then negotiating and then
valuing the relationship.
And it's just simple stuff.
Simple stuff.
- Simple when it's quiet in one's head.
Right?
Like, I've been thinking a lot about this.
Like, I wanted to ask you this.
How quiet and slow are things for you?
I've been thinking, and
here's how I'm saying it.
Like, you hear athletes talk about
when the game slows down.
- [Daymond] Yeah.
- I'm manic in my schedule,
and like, you know,
I'm also an extrovert by nature,
and so there's a lot of things
that go on with my energy,
and I wish there was a way
that I could explain to people
how slow everything feels to me.
- [Daymond] Same here.
- Good, I'm glad.
I thought that might make sense.
- Yeah, but that's why we see each other
on the road so much, and
people ask why we do it.
Why shouldn't I do it, you know?
- First of all, if you like it,
that's really the best part.
- I'm tweaking my life
and I'm making sure that,
all right, family needs to come out here,
I need to spend more time here,
I need to do more at this office,
I need more great people around me.
A lotta more Robins.
So I'm Batman and they're Robin.
They're Robin, I'm Batman half the time.
I need more of them
'cause I'm not gonna die,
I'm not going anywhere.
What am I gonna do?
And I'm educating myself
while I'm out there.
I'm expanding my network.
- Can you explain to the kids out here
how crazy you feel at 51,
how young and alive you feel?
Like, does that scare the 18-year-old you?
Could you have ever imagined
being this fresh at 51?
- No.
You know, when we were that
age, I was thinking like,
51 was, you know.
- I always tell the story.
My cousin Bobby was in
my dad's liquor store
when I got there.
He'd been there since he was 18.
He was 30 when I was 22
and got there full time.
I thought he was so fuckin' old.
30 seemed like.
That's why when I hang
out with the youngsters
that work for me, I'm like, "I get it."
Like, I always laugh.
I'm like, man, I think John
and Jason and I are the same,
and they think I'm fuckin' like their dad.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, no, no,
we're homies, like brothers.
And they're like, no, dad.
And I laugh about that because I'm 44.
30 seemed old as fuck.
Knowing, kinda your roots,
it must blow you away.
- I've been in 35, since
the new year started,
I've been in 35 cities.
- [Gary] That's amazing.
- But half of them are fun.
Golden Globes, McGregor
fight, Oscars, Super Bowl,
you know, whatever the case is.
Speaking and then hanging,
then taking my family
to the Bahamas and then
Cartagena for a wedding.
It's great!
- [Gary] Speed, speed.
- It's great.
It's great.
And yeah, it does move slow.
- LinkedIn, real quick, I apologize.
I want to get a little more
about what this book's about,
but I wanna use most of the majority
of the 20 to 30 minutes that, you know,
to answer some questions.
So, look, regardless of
what the book's about,
here's your chance to
ask Daymond a question.
So, put in your phone numbers on LinkedIn.
We're about to get some going in a minute.
But, I want Daymond to,
listen, anybody in our community,
listen, I'm not this person,
but if you're the person that
actually learns from books,
if you're part of this community,
I find it highly unlikely
that whatever discounted price
on Amazon or Barnes and Nobles
or where the fuck you can find this,
that it's not gonna be worth that ROI
if you know how to get
information outta book form,
so I highly recommend you picking it up
because I know this dude
doesn't put down bad product.
But, like, Daymond, for
the people that are like,
"Ah, fuck that, I don't
wanna spend 16 bucks."
If you can go narrow on to why this book,
versus just following you on social
or anything of that nature.
For me, when I write books,
I'm able to go deeper
on the shit that I'm
putting out headlines on,
and go narrow and then thus,
I think it's work 16 bucks.
I always think that way.
How do you think about this?
- Yeah, so first of all,
of course, you can get any
information from me free all the time.
CNBC, ABC, you know, all
my social media platforms.
- [Gary] All these BCC.
- Yeah, but of course,
of course, absolutely.
But if you wanna go narrow and deep
on how to basically create influence
and then how to negotiate
and how to develop those relationships,
then this goes granular into it.
I have about 10 subjects in there,
who have all went from
industry to industry
and become titans in various
different industries.
Pit Bull, my Bombas
socks guys, Kris Jenner,
Billy Jean King who
changed the face of tennis.
So this is not just--
- In tennis?
She changed the face of like, women.
- Women in sports, right?
So, this is obviously,
you were in my last book.
I only take subjects out
that I can learn from
on the same path as you are in this.
You know, when I'm talking to
somebody about negotiation,
a lot of people don't
realize this is really easy
because of social media.
People talk in five different ways,
and they communicate five different ways.
There's the sight, sound,
sight, sound, touch, taste, and smell.
And it's very simple.
If you're on social media,
you can look through peoples' feeds,
and you wanna talk to them.
It's like a used car salesman.
Used car salesman, you walk into the room,
he starts to listen,
or she starts to listen to
how you're communicating.
All right, there's a red Corvette there,
it has the top down.
If you're about sight, he goes,
"Can you see yourself
driving down the road,
"looking at the leaves
falling on a winding road?"
And if you're about smelling, he's like,
"Can you smell the rich leather?"
"Can you smell the air in the crisp air?"
If you're about sound, "Can
you hear the engine roaring?"
- That makes sense.
- You see?
And there's various ways of communication,
and you see us do it all
the time with "Shark Tank,"
'cause 65% of communication,
you know, is body language.
Only 7% is exactly what you're saying,
and the rest is how you said it, right.
And there's various
different ways to indicate
and go through a negotiation.
That's why when I get deals,
I can see when the person
putting their hand in their pocket,
putting their hair over their ear,
Robert sitting up and he closes his book.
You know, what's the name?
Kevin O'Leary always
wants to put something
in between you to create the distance.
And there's a lot of
information in this book
of keys on ways to
communicate, build influence,
and then nurture that relationship
to get way more after that.
- I love that.
Let's get some phone numbers in.
Who's the first person?
- Rodney.
- Rodney, all right.
While he's pulling up.
- Rodney!
All right.
- Yeah, that's interesting.
So, you think that there's a lot of--
- [Daymond] There's a lot
of nuggets in this book
that you take away two
and three or four of them,
they just helped you close one deal.
- One deal's are why positive.
(line trilling)
- They let you get the remote control
away from your wife or husband.
- [Rodney] Hello.
- Rodney?
- [Rodney] May I ask who's, yes?
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
You're on with Daymond John.
- [Rodney] Gary Vee, how you doing?
Daymond John, how you doing?
- I'm great.
What's happenin' Rodney?
- Rodney, where you from?
- [Rodney] I'm over here.
I'm from Miami, Florida.
- Let's go.
- [Rodney] But I'm livin'
in Atlanta right now.
- Oh I love it.
- [Rodney] And I'm
listening to you on LinkedIn
And you called me.
I was not expecting to sit up.
- Well, you put your
phone number on LinkedIn,
so it worked out.
- [Rodney] Hey, nothing much.
Hey, yeah, yeah, I got
a question for you man.
And I see that you and your brother
have your agency going on right now.
I'm pursuing my Master's
to become a sports agent.
Looking forward to that by the end,
by the beginning of next year
to be a certified sports agent.
What advice would you have
for a young guy like me,
entering that field there?
I got a background of playing football,
have friends in the NFL right now.
But for me starting out, you know,
being so close to the game,
what advice would you give to me
to become a successful sports agent?
- Let me give you my
take, and then Daymond,
see if you can fill out some spots.
So, the biggest thing I've learned,
AJ's been in the business now
for four years, VaynerSports.
The biggest thing that's really honest,
is that it's a lot more
simple than you think.
Like, I keep watching us lose,
let me go a different route.
The players that we
lose to other agencies,
where we're offering disproportionate
more impact financially
and infrastructure-wise,
strictly because that player liked
a different agent more than the agent
we put in front of them, whether that's AJ
or Brandon Parker or Tommy or Brian,
you will be blown away, my man,
of how much of this is
strictly being liked.
- [Rodney] Strictly being liked.
- You will be blown,
you're gonna go into this business
and be discouraged 'cause
you're gonna be like,
wait, the five biggest firms,
back to what Daymond said,
he's not gonna change that he was Black.
I'm not gonna change that I started at,
that I was not athletically inclined
or educationally inclined,
which made everybody
from the '70s and '80s feel like shit,
for the first 18 years of your life.
That doesn't change.
And I'll tell you this,
when you get into the game,
if you start small or a small firm,
you're gonna go what every agent does,
which is like woe is me.
It's CA, it's Roc Nation.
By the time you get into
it, we're like, on our way.
We have 13 guys in this draft.
It's been written.
We're gonna be a player.
But the reality is, I'm watching people
strictly pick people on likability,
nothing else.
Not what they can do.
Like, plenty of people go to Roc Nation
because they want their selfie with Jay-Z.
Plenty of people go to VaynerSports
'cause they want business
and life after football
and off the field stuff.
Plenty of people go to Athletes First
'cause Mulugheta's a great
agent and they built a thing.
There's a lot of places where people go.
I am stunned.
And I mean stunned, on how many people go
with a person they liked the most.
Liked.
- [Rodney] Right, and so--
But...
No, so right.
I'm a very likable guy.
I get along with a lot of people, man.
- Well, good news.
Good, good news.
Real quick and then I'll let
you jump in Jimmy, Daymond.
Good news.
You're gonna talk yourself
out of all the things.
You're gonna talk about
all these other things
that you need to do.
"Oh, we need to get marketing right.
"We need to be social media right.
"I gotta get some of my homies I played
"with football co-sign."
you're gonna think of
a million other things
that you're gonna learn matter,
and I'm telling you 50
fucking percent of it
is do human beings like you?
And if you actually
lean into that mentally,
you're gonna get real happy
'cause you're gonna realize
that you don't have to
work on all these things
that you think you have to work on.
Daymond.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
it's about the same thing.
You know, you gotta go narrow
and deep on your targets
that you want, and like he was saying,
you're gonna go everywhere.
But I think, also, the
co-signing of the people
that you already know,
that really do like you,
you could tell us you're likable,
but everybody's gonna be on
their first date telling you,
you know, your baby's beautiful, right?
Or they're beautiful.
You gotta dig deep into your database
and go after one, two
key players that like you
and that you like, and that
you can bring value to,
and just keep having these other
people also co-signing you.
Like he said, you're gonna
try to get all the people.
Just get one or two
people that really, really
mess with you to dig deep,
and you gotta, of course,
be out there doing your
homework and be ready
to pound the phones for
those cats, and let them
see that you're ready to just
put in the hours, you know?
- I'll give you two more insights
'cause I really want you to win.
One, everybody matters.
I went through this whole thing of like,
the parents matter, the
parents don't matter.
You know, the uncle matters,
the uncle doesn't matter.
The trainer matters, the
trainer doesn't matter.
The coach matters, but here's the rule.
- Everybody matters.
- Every fucking person matters
'cause we're influencing,
these are young kids.
And then finally, complete
and utter detachment.
You're gonna get your heart broke.
Some kid's gonna tell you you're his guy
all the way through, all the way through,
all the way through,
and then it's gonna come
to signing day and they're gonna call you
and be like, "Yeah, I'm
going with this other firm.
"I'm sorry, see ya."
- [Rodney] I've heard
those stories already.
Gary Vee, I was up there at
the Alabama Reese's Bowl game.
I was definitely looking for you.
I was trying my hardest
to look for you out there.
Saw you, saw you pulling
up out there on the field,
as I was leaving Alabama,
driving back to Atlanta.
But Daymond, I got a
question for you as well.
If I can shoot this
out there really quick.
- [Gary] Go quick.
- [Rodney] Would you say that
FUBU could make a comeback?
Would you bring FUBU back out?
A lot of people, this is in the south,
a brand, like Gary talks about,
but where can we see FUBU in the future?
- Yeah, you can go to
fubu.com and get that.
Yeah, it can make a comeback.
It all depends on how
much energy that I want
to put into it, and I have other partners
that have been putting energy into it,
but it absolutely can make a comeback.
It won't be on the same
platform as before,
just in retail.
It probably should be
a subscription service
or one of those things.
And absolutely, there's a
lot of content out there,
there's a lot of history,
it's a global brand.
But we need to get our ducks in order too.
- Thanks for the question.
- I got ya.
- Yeah, I mean, what
an iconic brand it is,
and I'm with you on that.
All right, let's get another one in.
Yeah, man, I'm shocked how much these kids
are smarter than ever but yet,
there's one kid who's
logically talked me through,
why we were disproportionally
right for him,
and then he said, "But
I'm going with another guy
"'cause it was love at first sight."
- [Kasari] Hello.
- Who's this?
- Kas, Kasari?
- [Kasari] Kasari.
- Kasari.
- Kasari, what's good?
- [Kasari] Hey, yo, Gary
Vee, my man, what's going on?
And Daymond, what's up?
- What's happening?
- [Kasari] Holy smokes,
man, I'm truly humbled
to even be talking to you guys right now.
Seriously.
- It's an honor.
- Thank you Kasari.
- [Kasari] Yo, so, my
question is, you know,
it's pretty simple but it's
pretty complicated, as well.
So right now, I live in Brooklyn,
I live with my mom and my
sister and my twin brother.
Three of us live in one single room.
- Rough.
- [Kasari] You know, so, it's
pretty challenging, you know.
And I have a passion.
- How old are you?
- I'm 22.
- Ooh.
- Keep going.
- [Kasari] I'm 22, I
just graduated school,
so I'm trying to figure out
life right now so I know what,
I 100% know that I want to go
into real estate investing.
That's really where I
see like, my business.
- Why?
- You know, going into it.
- Simply because I feel like
I can connect a lot of people and also,
the first time not having
a home where I can really
just kind of be myself and kind of expand.
That's really also something
that I just kind of,
you know, I wanna be
able to give other people
that opportunity in order to, you know,
have a nice place to live.
- Makes sense.
- So, right now,
I feel like the biggest struggle
for me has been, you know,
it's pretty much the energy, I guess,
like, in the house in a way.
So, just trying to figure out
what is it that I can do just to kind of
be at my best self.
'Cause back in school, you know, I was
crushin' it left and right, you know.
I was pretty much manifesting
everything that I wanted to,
and now I feel like it's
hard for me to take action.
- Why?
- [Kasari] I just feel like
it's the negative influences
of my parents and stuff like that.
- Why are you still home?
Is it that you're taking
care of your parents?
Are they disabled or anything like that?
'Cause you're 22.
- [Kasari] Well, so, the reason why
is New York's real expensive stuff.
Trying to save a bit of money.
- [Kasari] Just the kind
of, you know, stay at home
for as long as I could,
but right now, like I was--
- But have you--
- I'll let you, yeah.
- No, I'm sorry, please finish.
- [Kasari] Yeah, no, I was
actually debating, you know,
whether or not I should go
ahead and rent out an apartment.
Like, I know I would be rushing.
- I mean, it's really interesting.
It almost feels like
you're having a logical
and an emotional
conversation with yourself,
which I think we all do.
I love that you're thinking about saving,
and you have the humility
at 22 to be in your home,
which I love.
Are you also in a place where,
are your parents negative by nature?
Like, is that fucking you up?
- [Kasari] Yeah, so, look,
really where it's ending.
That my mom and my dad separated
when I was super young,
so my mom has been,
she put four kids through
college by herself.
- Beast.
- Good mom.
- [Kasari] You know, she makes
less than $20,000 a year.
- Beast.
- [Kasari] Super challenging for her
just to kind of balance everything,
so that's kind of where that
negative mindset comes from.
- Are you helping her?
- Yeah.
- Or are you saving because that's,
she's an amazing OG mom,
but she just happens to have, you know,
through all that adversity,
some negative vibes that are
potentially fucking you up.
- [Kasari] Right, I'll be honest with you.
- Please.
- I'm not helping her.
- That's what I thought.
- I've offered to,
but she's really super humble.
- She's proud, yeah, I get it.
- [Kasari] She wants me to save my money,
and kind of just go and
go after it in a way,
but you know, she's actually--
- Did you happen to see the post I put
over the weekend about
this concept of like,
build your crew, find other hungry people
and live an hour and a
half outside the city?
When you saw that, what did you think?
- [Kasari] You know, honestly,
I thought about doing that.
The only thing, I do I have a lot
of loser friends, you know.
They're all still going out partying.
Yeah, I'm 22-years-old, that's what I,
that's what most kids are doing my age,
but I've noticed like hey--
- When I posted the
second post where I said,
"Take over my account everybody
and find your people,"
and the hundreds of people that posted
in there that are from New York,
did it cross your mind to DM
like all of them and be like,
yo, do you wanna room up?
Or was it, what made you not think that?
- [Kasari] So, I thought about it, 100%.
For me, like, I'm very cautious
as to who I interact with.
- I respect that.
- Not who I interact with,
but who I live with in a way.
- I respect that.
- [Kasari] 'Cause I feel
like, you know, for me,
it's just all about
having the right energy.
And I guess that's kind
of like, limiting myself,
and beliefs in a way.
- But aren't you
in that scenario saying no
before you even met the fucking person?
- [Kasari] Yeah, 100%.
- Yeah, 'cause all you're
saying is your family
has negative energy and
your friends are losers.
So, you have no other option.
You can only go up by moving in with
a bunch of guys or girls.
You know, people come over
here from other countries
and they ain't got time to play.
They're coming over and
they're living in something
for $50 a week, and
they're busting their ass.
And there's full buildings
of them in New York,
of dancers and talented
people and tech people.
Why aren't you giving that
a shot, just for a month?
- Right.
- At least, you know.
Like, where are you finding your net?
Your networking is gonna be there.
- My problem with the way
the answers came out is,
the thing that I spend a
lot of time thinking about
is why are people saying no
before they've tried?
And the reason they're saying no is,
they're either not interested
in actually putting in the work
or they're insecure
and they're fear-based.
Which is okay.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I'm just trying to really
bring value on this call.
And I'm trying to really break down like,
are you also negative by nature?
You know, which is also fine.
I really mean that.
Like I'm trying to get like,
I want judgment out the fucking window.
I want assessment and action.
Right?
Listen, me being positive and optimistic
is literally completely
predicated on the fact
that my parents had sex
at that exact moment,
and gave me that DNA.
I have no pride in that I'm optimistic.
That was fucking Chance City, USA.
So, as a matter of fact,
that leads to gratitude
and guilt and deep humility and compassion
for others because, guess what?
My sister is not that.
And I've watched her,
I respect my sister more than me.
Those things came natural to me.
Like, I respect the fact
that I got into shape
more than I have all these talents,
'cause I actually feel
like I worked for that.
This was gifted.
You just like, you saying
no, for the other party,
by the way, I fully agree with you.
I do not think that you should live
with people that you don't jive with.
You fucking decided that every person
that left a comment in my
post was negative energy.
You said no before you said yes.
- [Kasari] Right, right.
- See, yes, I did the reverse.
I did the reverse when
I first started FUBU.
We were fortunate enough to have a house.
I went to work at Red Lobster for anywhere
about 50 hours a week, and
then I would come home,
work on FUBU for 30 hours a week.
I would sleep three nights,
three hours a night.
I had sewing machines in my living room,
and I slept next to the sewing machines,
and I rented out my bedroom,
and all the bedrooms
in my house for $25 a piece
because I wanted those,
to strangers, to pay the mortgage,
and they helped pay the mortgage.
I was getting money over at Red Lobster,
from my day job, and that helped me
do FUBU for five years.
I would've had to do $2
million in sales in FUBU
to make the same amount of
money I walked away with,
and I wouldn't have done that,
and I wouldn't have had FUBU.
I just had to make another sacrifice.
And some people paid,
and some people didn't.
I got robbed in my hallway,
my bathroom hallway one day.
It is what it is.
But, you know, I kicked
people out, and that's it man.
You know, you just have
to have to act on it.
- [Gary] K, can I ask you a question?
- [Kasari] Yeah, absolutely.
- How much entitlement or not entitlement
do you think you have?
Like, from a self-assessment.
'Cause I think a lot about this.
It's a really difficult
question to ask somebody.
Like, hey, how entitled are you?
Nobody wants to be like,
oh, super fucking entitled.
But on the flip side,
I do think entitlement and humility
is an interesting framework
for all of us to go through
because if you're lucky enough on it,
then or to figure it out,
it can be really good.
- [Kasari] Right, so
I'll be honest with you,
you know, I grew up my whole life
pretty much having nothing.
Literally, there were days
where I wouldn't even eat,
or I would only have the
meals that I had in school.
And I would come home and wait
those kind of eight hours,
10 hours and go to breakfast,
run over and just kind of go from there.
So, that made me super humble, you know,
just being afraid and
grateful and appreciative
of what I do have.
It's great, because, you
know, but back in school,
back in college, people always
saw me as a positive person,
but I was never negative
or anything like that.
I feel like being home,
I'll be honest with you,
has made me slightly more negative now,
in the sense that, you know,
that energy just kind of rubs off on me.
So, right now, so in terms
of kind of my entitlement,
I feel like I've gotten
slightly a little more entitled,
in the sense that like,
hey, why can't I just have
a regular place to live in a way,
which is kind of where this
negative energy comes from.
- But you can, right?
I guess my questions is,
have you got caught up
in New York's expensive
and I have no options?
- [Kasari] Right, exactly.
And that's literally what it is.
- I'm sorry, I got a little distracted.
Do you have a job?
- [Kasari] I do.
- Okay, so fucking commute longer.
Bro, bro, hold on, Daymond, I apologize.
Hold on, hold on, Daymond.
I really apologize.
Bro, commute further.
- [Kasari] Mm-hmm.
- Like, who the fuck said you had to live
in Williamsburg, Bushwick, or Manhattan?
There's people at VaynerMedia that commute
two and a half hours to be here.
I don't know.
This is where I'm going.
I'm coming from love, and
I hope you can feel it.
- [Kasari] No, no, I 100%, I respect it.
- And I feel like you can pick it up too.
I'm excited about this.
I'm trying to, on some real option shit,
why not move far as fuck
and commute two hours every morning?
- [Kasari] So, Gary, I was
gonna ask you actually.
- Please.
- I really wanna,
I planned on, you know,
investing in New Jersey,
like Union County and stuff like that.
So, should I just move over there,
and just be like fuck it, like go get it,
and just figure it out later?
- I can say this.
I can say this based on what I'm hearing,
and this is a hot take off of fucking
nine minutes and 40 seconds.
I think that you should
definitely get outta the house.
- [Kasari] Okay.
- And so, for me, whether
it's Union, New Jersey,
which you're arbitrarily picking, like,
dude it sounds like you're very far away
from real estate investing.
No?
- [Kasari] So, my whole plan was to work
with other investors
that have been in the
game for quite some time.
- Okay.
- Bring them deals,
and kind of have them pay me from that.
- From leads, I get it.
- [Kasari] While also
learning before I get like,
you know, stuff like that.
- Yeah.
I just think there's a huge opportunity
for you to live further away
where you can afford it, and you're good.
I think people pick convenience and like,
to me, an extra hour commute
for that mental happiness
is a monster win for you.
You were the fucking man at school
'cause you had freedom.
I'm just like cool, we won this game.
Move an hour further away,
get a little less sleep or
a little less convenience.
On that hour commute, the
extra hour on the train,
you get a lot of shit done,
and you're gonna be happy as fuck.
- [Kasari] Yeah.
I got you.
But look, I think that's
what I'm gonna end up doing,
in that case.
- That makes sense to you, right?
'Cause that's why I
asked about entitlement.
Like, yes, I know you wanna save,
and I love you for that.
I fucking love you for that.
You've also assessed that
the environment's negative.
So, I'm like wait a minute,
you could win both here.
You can really drive down your rent,
if you're just willing to
live an hour and a half
from the city.
This is New York City,
the most expensive place.
If you go an hour and a half commute
outside of here, shit gets cheaper.
- We don't necessarily
know that mom's negative.
Mom busted her ass and put
four kids through college.
Maybe she's telling him
some of things that we said.
Maybe she's telling him some of the shit.
- I'm a fucking fan of mom.
- Maybe she's telling him
some of the shit he
don't wanna hear either,
but you know, you never know, right.
But either way, he gotta go
out and do it on his own.
- Whether she's right or he's right,
he just needs to eliminate
another excuse, right?
- Exactly.
- To your point, she might,
By the way, K, I think
you might know this.
She might be right.
It's actually irrelevant.
You're on it Daymond.
Like, she's a G.
Single mom, put four fucking
people through school?
She's a fucking gangster.
- Let there be no confusion.
- Right.
- Her execution--
- Doesn't want anything now.
- Are you kidding me?
A fucking gangster.
- No, I do respect that.
- Now it's a small space.
All I want you to do is
eliminate the excuse of your mom.
I'm telling you this, not
because I'm shitting on her.
I'm actually shitting on the situation,
and I'm hopeful that if you
move an hour and a half out,
notice what I asked you.
How entitled are you?
- [Kasari] Mm-hmm.
Look, and I have no problem moving
an hour and a half out.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't mind eating shit for the next
five, 10, 15 years of my
life, just to kind of--
- That's amazing.
- Be where I want to be.
- So good news, move out,
and make it inconvenient.
- [Kasari] Gotcha.
And now what about in terms
of kind of like, saving money?
Should I just budget better in that case?
- Yeah.
- Until I figure things out.
- If you're truly trying to save money,
and now you've taken on 500
or $1,000 more of expenses,
all of a sudden,
every nice little thing you
like has to be looked at.
- [Kasari] Yeah.
I mean, that's literally--
I don't buy clothes, I don't go out,
I don't do anything.
I just buy books and just read and--
- [Daymond] Good man.
- Don't buy books.
- Don't buy books?
- The Internet's free as fuck.
- Uh-huh.
- Like, I'm being serious.
Like, every book, like pirate 'em.
Pirate, pirate that shit.
Go Google fucking,
go look at "Powershift" and "Crush It"
on fucking Pirate Bay,
or if that's still around.
- It's not up, it's not up right now.
- Fucking steal it.
- It's not up, it's not up.
- Steal that shit.
- [Kasari] Daymond, do you endorse this?
I know you got a book coming out.
- [Gary] Of course he endorses it.
Of course he endorses it.
We both lived it.
- I endorse, I endorse.
- Go to garage sales and
buy the book for a quarter.
- Absolutely.
- Like fuck $15 on Amazon
when you fucking are
building in the beginning.
Don't buy shit.
- [Kasari] I got ya.
- People don't know how to save anymore.
- [Kasari] Yeah, and that's
always the hard part,
and you know even back in college,
I would put every little
paycheck that I got,
saving, saving, saving, saving,
and you know, I'm building up my credit--
- You know what's happening right now?
This is where you're
getting caught, I think.
Tell me if I'm wrong.
- [Kasari] Yeah.
- The fact that you're not
paying rent and saving,
is allowing you to spend
money on a couple things
that you wouldn't have,
and that's where the cycle's playing.
- [Kasari] No, honestly, not really.
- Good.
- [Kasari] The only expenses
that I have right now
is just food, and my commute,
like my train ticket.
And that's really it.
- Good.
I believe you.
Then I would say for happiness,
instead of this happening in 11 years,
let it happen in 14 years,
by moving an hour and a half out.
- [Kasari] Again, one
more thing, you know,
and this is also kind of
like with my job and stuff.
I feel like, it's just a lot of people
who don't care about saving
and just every other day,
just going out for drinks
and stuff like that.
- Who gives a fuck?
Their life has nothing,
who gives a fuck?
- [Kasari] Right.
- That's good.
I like when everybody
else is doing dumb shit.
That means I'm about to win.
- [Kasari] Yeah, they're
just pretty much--
- What, are you feeling,
wait a minute, wait a
minute, are you telling me
that you feel FOMO when everybody goes out
- [Kasari] No, no, no.
I don't feel FOMO.
- On fucking thirsty Thursday
and drinks a fuckin' mojito?
- [kasari] (laughs) No, I don't feel FOMO,
but I just feel like if
people aren't focused
like I'm focused and them
have the same goals--
- Bro, let me tell you,
let me tell you something really good.
Don't judge anyone.
- [Kasari] Okay.
- You see where I'm going?
I'm watching a lot of judgment come from,
now, I'm starting to
spend some time with you.
If we were having a four
hour dinner, as homies,
I'd be like, "Bro, stop judging people."
- No, no, no, no.
He gonna judge you after
he gets off the phone.
- But like, you see where
I'm going though, bro?
- [Kasari] Yeah, I got that
from my mom, but yeah I see you.
- I got love for you too.
Like, honestly, be empathetic.
Be grateful that you're not in a...
I've been trying to tell people,
"I don't have advice."
I'm like every other human.
We're animals that like
to share hypotheses,
opinions, our hot takes,
but like, don't judge them.
- [Kasari] Yeah.
- And don't envy them.
I hate when people are like,
"Damn, yeah, 'cause his
dad's paying for his shit,
"he gets to go to the club."
And?
Deep down, he fucking thinks he's a loser
because his dad's paying for everything.
Next, next.
Like, "Oh damn, they're
just buying those drinks
"or those clothes to fit in."
Don't judge them, feel bad for them,
that their whole life
is about other people's
fucking acceptance, so
they have to fucking
ruin their own lives just so
everybody thinks they're cool.
I think you're spending a
lot of time on judgment.
Don't even think about it.
I knew nothing.
I knew nothing of what
anybody was doing in my 20's.
I didn't know if they
were winning, losing,
going out, not going
out, unless they walked
in the fucking liquor store,
which some of them did,
I literally had no fucking idea.
Get quiet and focus on your own shit.
- [Kasari] I love that,
that's what I gotta do.
- Does that makes sense to you?
- [Kasari] Yeah, no look,
I feel like that was,
I feel like I've been struggling with this
for the past, literally,
six to eight months,
since I graduated.
And I feel like this is
giving a little more clarity,
and like a plan of action.
- And K, I'll tell you something else.
You're probably judging 'cause they're is
a little underlying envy and FOMO,
which is okay 'cause we're humans.
- Yep.
- Right.
- You see where I'm going?
- [Kasari] Right, right, right.
No, 100%, I see it.
- And that's okay.
- [Kasari] For me, like it's just,
I feel like I'm not
taking the strides towards
where I wanna be.
- You're impatient.
You're six fucking,
you're eight months in.
- We all were impatient,
though, at that age.
Now you know better.
- No, no, don't--
- I like, I like how he said he's willing
to eat shit for 15 years.
- Hold on, let's create some clarity
'cause I know a little
bit about your narrative.
- Don't confuse ambition with lack of,
you were patient.
- Yeah, I was patient.
- Okay.
- I was patient,
but I was patient because I was making
as many moves and mistakes as I could,
and I was saying, "All
right, this is something--
- Learning, learning.
- "Not interested in."
- And I'm learning.
And I kept moving forward
and I kept moving forward.
- That's different than
when you're impatient
and you start fucking
looking at things from a,
you were happy and patient.
- Yeah.
- Too many people are sad and impatient
because they can't wait
to get to the finish line
without fucking even warming up.
- Yeah.
- Bro, you're 40 seconds in.
- [Kasari] Yeah, no, I see that.
- What, do you think you're gonna be
a fucking real estate tycoon by 24?
What the fuck?
- [Kasari] I'm 22-years-old, and in a way,
I feel like I gotta have life figured out.
- Go to sleep for the next 10 years.
Don't even call me until you're 32
and don't talk to nobody.
Go to sleep.
Go hibernate for a decade.
And just fucking eat shit
and work and be patient,
and then maybe kinda sorta
at 32, young as fuck,
maybe we can have a conversation.
About something, maybe.
- [Kasari] Yeah.
- Everybody's fucking deciding at 22.
You're fucking eight months outta school.
- [Kasari] But it's
great, 'cause I feel like
I know what I want to be doing.
I'm just, you know--
- Me too.
Me too.
I knew I wanted to win
a fucking Super Bowl
as the owner of the New York Jets,
so I decided to be patient
for 52 fucking years.
I knew too.
Good news, me too.
Now what?
I didn't say a peep, and I
fucking worked at a liquor store,
in the fucking basement for 15 years
before I even popped my head
up to make a YouTube video.
Didn't say a word, didn't go to a club,
didn't buy shit.
Fucking worked.
And, punchline, built it
for my dad and started over
in the fucking conference room at 34.
- Are you watching?
Do you see how Gary's
eyeballs are bulging?
- [Kasari] (laughs) No
that's just passion, yeah.
I mean, you can't get that
anywhere else, I respect that.
- And what I want for you is,
and you know what I want for you?
Patience and self-awareness.
People lose by being impatient.
Patience, bro, it's super real,
and it's super hard.
- [Kasari] It is, it is.
I feel like I've been,
I've been working on that tremendously.
I feel like that's what's
given me my success.
Back in school, now it's kinda--
- Hold on, before we go any further,
now I'm really caught
up in this narrative.
Tell me about school and success.
- No, no, no, no, no.
He got the band camp.
He got that one day in band camp.
He got that Al Bundy shit like this,
because when he was in
school, he was hot and sexy,
and now he went back to the
hood and he's eating shit.
- Well, here's the thing--
- And now he's like,
"I don't deserve this."
- I don't know how about that.
Go ahead K.
- No, no, and he's like,
"I don't deserve this."
- K.
- [Daymond] I was sexy at
school, back in band camp.
- Why were you sexy at school?
- [Kasari] No, I wouldn't say I was sexy.
- You were happy.
- You were in band camp.
- [Kasari] I was living
life in a good way.
- Why?
- So pretty much--
- [Kasari] I feel like my
mission was to kind of, you know,
be that positive light
in other people's life.
- Okay.
- And I feel like just having
those self worries about myself,
and everything that I've
been through in my life,
I feel like if I can translate that story
and share it with others,
and you know, just kind of,
I was really like, kind
of like, a mini Gary Vee,
that's really what people were calling me.
You know, and then that led to me,
awards and stuff like that,
that means absolutely shit.
- But you're gonna appreciate this.
The part that gets
confusing about Gary Vee
to a lot of people is I fucking, like,
I'm positive and optimistic
but it's all based on merit and execution.
- [Kasari] Right.
- You can't build a business
on just being positive and optimistic,
like, that's not my business.
- [Kasari] Right.
- That's my giving.
- [Kasari] Right, and
the what's it called?
And back in school, you
know, like, I had a good GPA.
- Respect.
- I was an academic.
- But I was also social
in the sense that, you know--
- You were happy.
- [Kasari] I was happy, I was social.
- He's back in the hood, eating shit.
And he's remembering back in band camp.
- K, do you think that's right?
I'm curious.
- [Kasari] I don't think it's right,
but it showed me a new side of me
that I've never seen before,
you know, now that I've been back home.
- Right, mom busts her ass
to put him in the environment
where he blossomed in band camp,
and now he's going back
to shit and wondering,
"Why aren't times good like before?"
- K?
- Kind of, yeah.
And the way--
- And now, "Mom, it's your fault."
I put my name on the milk in the fridge.
Don't touch that, that's mine, mommy.
- [Kasari] I actually don't do that.
But I see where you're coming
from and also it's like,
I know I have the potential within myself,
and in a way it kind of gets frustrating
when I feel like I'm being
limited, me being at home.
- So, but here's the best part.
Nobody's keeping you at home.
- [Kasari] Right.
- You're choosing to be at home.
- Matter of fact, Mom's like,
"Nah, don't give me nothin'."
- Yeah, Mom's killing it.
I'm about Mom.
- Mom's kinda feel, "You
need to leave homie."
I already said hold that.
- Okay, she, one more time.
- Hold that.
- [Kasari] She doesn't want me leaving.
- Of course, 'cause nobody
wants their baby leaving.
- I don't know, if you ask my mother,
she kick me out.
She was like, "You on your own, you're 16,
"you know what I mean,
go about your business,
"go get that paper."
- Bro, you need to be careful here
because if she doesn't want you leaving,
and she paid for your college,
you're getting coddled.
- [Kasari] Mm-hm.
She doesn't want me leaving
because she's scared
of being alone, in a way.
- 'Cause nobody else is there?
- [Kasari] Well, like,
she has my siblings,
but she's scared that--
- Hold on.
- [Kasari] When everyone leaves,
she's gonna be there by herself.
- No, no.
That has nothing to do with you.
You're being coddled, you know that right?
Do you know how many people
right now in my community,
are like mad as hell at you
because they're in debt?
And they have nowhere to go.
You know that right?
- [Kasari] Yeah.
- You need to be careful
here, in a good way.
This is why this is fun.
This is all love, as you can tell.
- It's all love, man.
- All love.
The energy--
- We give you tough love and
smart love and all that love.
- [Kasari] All right, this is what I need.
- Yeah, listen man, you
need to be careful here.
You need to be real careful here
because your mom is fucking amazing
and a lot of times, when
I talk about parents,
that create fake environments,
we always paint them
as super rich, white families.
What we don't talk enough about
is immigrants or humble
fucking work their whole lives
for their kids, and put their kids on,
and you need to be careful
here because you're coddled.
- [Kasari] Mm-hm.
- And I wanna see every receipt,
because the second you
bought one cup of Starbucks,
I'm mad at you.
- I've never bought Starbucks.
- Respect.
- I don't even drink coffee.
- Respect, bro.
But I'm really serious on this,
on you might be coddled.
You know that right?
- [Kasari] Mm-hmm.
Right, absolutely.
- Like, it's rare to not have to pay rent.
It's rare.
It's rare, real quick,
it's rare for your parent
to pay for college completely.
- It's rare for you to
be able to not pay rent.
So, you might be getting
caught because you're entitled.
- [Kasari] I mean, I'm super
humble by the fact that,
you know, I don't have to pay rent.
- No, no, you're appreciative.
- [Kasari] Oh yeah, super
appreciative about that fact.
- But humility, you
know, comes in the form
of, like, you started
this call with, you know,
friends are losers and
negative energy in a home
you're not paying for.
- Yeah.
- That's called non-accountability.
- Right humility comes with,
Mom, how can I add more value to you?
What can I do to get outta this house."
- Or, or--
- And get things done.
And help you with my siblings.
- And you're using the excuse of mom
doesn't want me to leave.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause she said she loves you
and loves having you around.
- [Kasari] Right.
- Fake environment, bro.
- It is.
You know, and in all honesty,
I actually even when I do leave,
I think it may hurt her in one aspect,
but I feel like once she's
sees that I'm doing well,
like, even me going away to
college was tough for her.
- Of course, bro.
- But if she sees me,
yeah.
- Of course parents love their kids,
especially the way that
you're painting your mom.
Here's the other thing.
She's ready for you to be a man.
I promise.
- My favorite movie's "Step Brothers,"
and they lived in the
house till they were 40.
- [Gary] I gotta make a family call.
Daymond, you're gonna have
to close out the show.
K, I love you, I'm being dead serious.
- Okay, great.
- Plug away for four minutes.
I love you.
- All right.
All right man.
- Sell your fucking book.
K, I gotta go, I really--
- All right man.
- [Kasari] Appreciate you so much, Gary.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- Gary.
- [Gary] It's the first time someone else
is closing the show.
You got five minutes, go.
- Anyway, so we're gonna close out, man.
And I'm gonna take one more call,
but I want you to remember the one thing.
"Powershift" is a exclusive
ownership of Daymond John,
and it is watermarked.
Any rebroadcast and/or
downloading of content illegally,
you will go to the chair.
(both chuckling)
All the best, brother.
- [Kasari] Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
- Peace.
- Daymond, you're a legend.
- Thank you man.
- I appreciate you so much.
- That was a great call.
I liked that one with Gary.
He, I don't know, we went back and forth.
Loved him, hated him, got in his ass.
That was really absolutely amazing.
Let's do one more call.
This next segment is brought
to you by "Powershift".
(laughing)
(phone ringing)
Gary Vee's favorite book.
He uses this all the time.
I sent him a copy, changed his life.
Who's on the phone?
(line trilling)
- MacGuyver.
- MacGuyver!
I already like this guy.
I'm gonna like him more if it's a girl.
- [Intern] Wow.
You wanna leave 'em a voicemail?
- Yeah.
- [MacGuyver] Oh, hello, sorry.
- MacGuyver?
- [MacGuyver] Yeah, it's him.
- How you doing?
This is Daymond John, here.
I'm taking the place of Gary Vee
for the last call of the broadcast.
How ya doing?
- [MacGuyver] No way, bro, that's dope!
- Yeah, I think it's kinda fresh.
- [MacGuyver] Yeah, I'm
good man, how bout yourself?
- I'm good, how you doing,
where you calling from?
Or where we calling you at?
- [MacGuyver] From Seattle, Washington.
- All right, all right, represent.
So, you got a question or
comment or something like that?
- [MacGuyver] Yeah man, I just
honestly wanna say I soak up
you guys' content non-stop, man.
I had a troubled upbringing,
I guess you could say.
Dropped out after 10th
grade, the whole nine.
But I got an opportunity
in the business world once,
and that was a part time
minimum wage graphic designer.
I got better at communicating with people,
and basically moved up in the company.
Actually found a lot of success man,
but honestly a lot of
it's attributed to guys
like yourself and Gary Vee.
You know, you pour into us
and allow us to soak it up
and go get it.
- Wow, that's impressive, man.
- Thank you, I don't--
- That--
- I just wanna say thank you.
- I appreciate it.
That's impressive.
I want people to know that
they don't necessarily,
and I'm not saying anything's
wrong with college.
If you can't afford, you
know, to go to college,
people like you and me.
I barely finished high school.
We went out there and we busted our butt,
and that's really honestly
what the book is about.
Like creating influence.
You moved up in the company then,
you said you moved up in the company, why?
Why, was it because of
purely your talents?
Or the way you work with people?
- [MacGuyver] It's a couple of things.
I would say it's hard work.
I knew everyone else had
degrees and things like that,
and I didn't, so I gotta
work 10 times harder.
I'm naturally good with people.
I'm one of those cats you can put me in
any scenery, any block, and I'll get along
with anybody and everybody.
- Swiss Army knife.
- [MacGuyver] Know how to kinda,
yeah, yeah, exactly, bro, a
little chameleon, you know,
capability in a sense.
And then just caring for people, bro,
and being genuine and honest and,
you know, I started out
as the third employee.
When I left, we had about 15 employees,
and I actually started as a
minimum wage graphic designer,
15, 20 hours a week,
and I actually became VP
of the company.
And continued to grow.
- Good for you, man.
- Further opportunities since then, bro,
so just, I'm thankful, man.
That's for sure.
- I think you just hit it on the head.
You know, when Gary was
talking to the gentleman
earlier today, talking about, you know,
being a sports agent,
people need to like you.
I mean, the whole theory of "Powershift",
the whole theory of
"Powershift" is that you have
to build influence.
And how do you build influence?
Look, you dropped out of school,
you went to a company, you
were getting minimum wage
as a designer or assistant designer,
you moved up to be the VP.
The reality is that whether you are,
you know, in "Powershift",
whether you're trying
to get a better job, get
an investment from me,
or do something else,
people want to be around people they like.
People want to be around
people that they can
sit next to for eight hours
a day, five days a week,
for the next five years.
And if you're a problem
solver, and you shift power
to other people when you see
that they can do something,
and they shift power back to you,
and then you nurture those relationships,
you're doing exactly why
I wrote the book on this.
Too many people out there
use it as an excuse.
It's people out there
that would have been you
and said, I dropped out of school.
I'm only starting on minimum wage.
I got all these hours, they're
never gonna respect me.
The company's only three people.
It's never gonna grow to 15.
And that's exactly the mentality,
so I thank you as well
for learning from Gary,
me, and all the other
people out there who just
take the time to put the
information out there
free or anywhere you can find it.
And I hope you're doing the same
for the people coming up underneath you.
- [MacGuyver] Oh absolutely, man.
I'm involved heavily in the community
and in the business world,
and I'm actually been working on wanting
to start something called
Creative Culture one day.
And creative kinda stands for community
of real entrepreneurs
and aspiring trailblazers
with imperfections that add value.
And really, it's just about
empowering other people.
Like, if I can do it as
a high school drop-out,
got two felonies when I turned 18,
the whole nine, you know what I mean.
I should not be where I am today.
I still got my ups and downs,
but I definitely should not have
the opportunities I've had.
If I can do it, any Joe Schmoe can,
you know what I mean,
and I wanna help those
get out and get some power to the people.
We're all imperfect, we
all got our struggles,
but we're better together if we get rid
of that facade and help
enable one another,
we're all gonna win long-term.
You know what I mean?
- I feel exactly like you do,
and I wanna make sure that
the people listening, too,
needs to understand that the mentality
of an entrepreneur can
be used within a system.
You know, when I'm at my company,
all my people think as entrepreneurs.
Because if I was the only
one thinking like that,
these guys would just
be putting, you know,
round pegs in round holes.
But if you're an entrepreneur,
you think within the system.
I need to depend on my staff and people,
like you, who think like entrepreneurs.
So, Gary Vee's back.
I don't know if you
got a question for him.
I think we're gonna sign
off right after that.
We got a great on here,
who dropped outta school.
- [MacGuyver] No, I just
wanna say thank you.
- Yeah, okay.
- [MacGuyver] I just
wanna say thank you, bro.
Man, I'm so stoked you guys called
and asked me that on
there just as a long shot
and it happened, so I'm stoked, man.
- Yeah.
- I'm happy for you.
- Yeah, he dropped outta high school.
He dropped outta high school 10th grade,
started a minimum wage job as a designer
in a company with three people,
moved up to vice president,
and is crushing it, so.
- [Gary] Love, congratulations.
Thanks, Daymond, for holding it down.
- All right.
- All right, fellas.
- All right, buy the book.
"Powershift" is out March...
- 10th.
Ted?
That's good.
- That's it.
- That's great.
- Ted, when you wanna do that call out
if anybody hits us on our
DM or something like that?
- Oh yeah, what do you want Ted?
I see you growth hacking.
I like it.
- We'll do something here for people
who didn't get a chance to--
- By the way, Ted started as a intern.
He's the President of my company.
I listen to Ted.
- Yeah, Ted's my boss too.
Every time I see him,
I feel like I have to
answer to him too, for no reason.
Like, sorry Ted.
- I appreciate that, thank you.
So, we're doing something
called the 10 for 10 challenge.
So, if you get 10 copies of "Powershift,"
and DM Daymond the receipt on Instagram,
he will pick 10 people
that Daymond will call
to talk about their
business for 10 minutes.
- I love that.
- Skype or call 'em?
I'll call 'em.
- Yeah, we'll do whatever
the person wants to do.
- Skype or call or whatever.
- You know, yeah, we
don't need to give fucking
Daymond's number to be
out there and weird shit.
- But 10 copies, DM to
Daymond on his Instagram,
and we will pick 10 people
- I love that.
- For Daymond to talk to.
- [Gary] I like the growth hack.
- All right, well, thank
you all, thank everybody,
thank you Gary Vee
Thank you everybody here,
for investing themselves,
spending their time with us.
They could be anywhere in the world.
- And they chose to be with us tonight.
Cool.
(crew laughing)